in the quadboss i'll market in
port-au-prince Haiti customers sift
through a notion of secondhand clothing
commonly known as Pepe Calais containers
of Pepe are sent here from the United
States each year leading many to think
of the country as a dumping ground for
American castoffs ICPs cotton a on
poubelle cote tota yo pavo's way not rub
a little on CTC although formal research
on the market is limited Pepe has been
coming to Haiti since at least the 1960s
when governments and charities began to
send donated goods to the country in
bulk
living la kill easy now security was in
bed the government energy IG if he
difficult cutter legally Pepe
these sorts of donations to the
developing world have been criticized
for undercutting local producers and
sellers but the pet day market is
decidedly a business not a charity
most Pepe comes by way of Haitian
Americans purchasing at thrift stores
abroad and shipping product to Haitian
ports the rise of the Pepe market in the
1980s did decimate Haiti's class of
professional tailors who used to supply
most of the clothing worn here
relatively few tailors remain today and
the work they have is limited rajanbabu
I could divide I've been buzzing about
the Bonneville affair
Simone is only from Bolivia politely
call today a proxy Elmo knows no
activity that was a nice - nobody the
damage to the domestic industry has also
angered some Haitians who believe that
Pepe Hertz the local economy more than
it helps and some had even called for
the government to regulate imports to
the benefit of the old clothing
producers Monza pet juice employ leap
Oscar de Papa table good moon given CCO
Popov Popov on see Sri Lanka posture
Lipitor en una to fatten up a pendulum
mmm important a papaya da da capo Kapil
but despite these criticisms average
Haitians enjoy having access to
affordable and high quality apparel the
average Haitian earns only about 650
dollars a year and Pepe provides a
source of cheap and stylish clothing and
while Pepe markets may depend on
Americans donations to thrift stores
dubbing all secondhand clothing in Haiti
unwanted castoffs is a misnomer
I di self agape enough really clear
there are made by general customers here
have specific tastes and preferences as
do customers anywhere and sellers look
to meet buyer demand
it's why you're likely to see as many
pairs of Chuck Taylors on the streets of
port-au-prince as you are Brooklyn CVI
finally the gobble I built in Nepal in
my life lost one bit because I the
maxilla and these sales provide
employment small merchants known as tea
marshawn sell Pepe and shops and on
street corners throughout the country
and countless vendors make their livings
this way nor fair even
we've unified Takata son missing really
poor Kyle fella to borrow for Adam
although it comes into the country by
the bail many merchants sift through
item by item to find just the right Pepe
for their local market for vendors like
Linda Lucien Pepe is more than unwanted
hand-me-downs
it's her product inventory couple people
and Nancy Lisa Marie man silly mistakes
silicon palate soo much American no
every living to slow denied see good
time again to die cinema baby
it may be inevitable that many Americans
old apparel winds up impeded but most
stations prefer the global Pepe trade
that gives them the option to wear
brands like polo and converse to not
having access to these products at all
foreigners shouldn't see Haiti as a
trash can for dumping anything and
everything they no longer want but the
afterlife of American clothes in Haiti
involves much more than unwanted
castoffs maybe ideas ideas ideas a dozen
easy way I say I mean imagining them in
fat so lemme do it